[Music]
dictionary.com has added a new term to
describe these relevant terms that we
have these days like Sam yeah hey better
person yeah more like these time more
like the road oh that's an actual word
[ __ ] Rona Rona slang it's it's referring
to covin 19 and in the example I'm not
even trying for a beachbody this year
since Rona ruined my summer plan
I feel so bad for all the Rona's out
there now yeah like Sharona is that a
name Rona sounds like it could be a
female's name it does or Corona I think
people have an R on us yeah does that
sound like a real thing at Rona yeah I
think a shortened version of Sharona and
Rinaldo yeah oh yeah in Spanish to say
Bonita a cutter Anita Anita Quran Nona
eat that it's kid right my views
coronavirus do they call Italy in Karami
huh damn do they call it the Quran in
Italy next one is nothing Corona the
eros eros why not
it's because that's how reporters say a
novel coronavirus novel means new mmm
that's what that means
oh did you guys know that like what
kovin like novel coronavirus like The
Cove in nineteen it means coronavirus
disease somebody 19 yes the iteration of
the disease and the fact that it's in
you and the fact that you came out in
2019 correct we talked about this months
ago well when we have the doctor on the
novel because the actual thing is like
SARS v2 something right that's the SARS
Co V - something like that yeah so many
[ __ ] letters just make the sickness
go away yeah
chitra preach [ __ ] man so it says
pathology a coronavirus that has not
previously been detected or reported
example the public health threat of
novel corona viruses such as Cullen 19
yeah so maybe that's just for reporters
that say all the time because nobody in
regular life says that the novel
coronavirus
know most people call it the Ronis Rona
I always hear Rona does have a
definition where it says Wuhan is is
where Chinese people eat bats or Jim is
that the next slide yeah social distance
that wasn't a word before there wasn't
thing no it's like they have updated it
to reference these time so it says like
sociology the extent to which
individuals or groups are removed from
or excluded from participating in one
another's lives I'm - is safer
appropriate distance or amount of space
between two people or between people in
a group the example is security concern
concerns demand that officers maintain a
social distance from inmates they had a
social distance of a few feet from
anyone who was coughing or sneezing verb
to maintain a safe or appropriate
distance from other people especially to
slow the spread of a contagious illness
or disease the example is moms trying
hard to social distance though she
misses her weekly bingo game it sounds
like introverts life I feel like this
phrase before I was just like you and
use it when you were just trying to get
away from someone annoying I'm socially
distancing myself from this oh that's
true we're socially distancing a word
that's been popping up that I never
really heard before was stir-crazy oh
yeah I've been saying that a lot where
being in in one place and you're going
crazy you're going inside to your Stern
around because you're it's like you're
stuck oh I thought it meant like you
stick your dick inside and you
stir-crazy
how would you do that job you stick it
inside and the girls go wild they go
crazy
I thought you sticking your dick in
crazy and then Easterns turn but I want
to see like I can't picture the the act
of
stirring so how's that have you heard of
a spinner have you heard of a spinner
where your this way and in the girl
stack get girl gets on and then she
spins right I think short the see right
hip small that's what I'm asking
it feels really good picture and joy
just to see how your hips move because
it goes like this you go in and then you
go like that
that's a kazoo I can't picture it job no
she sits on your dick like that so
imagine or standing oh there you go I
think she can see a better da and but
but then she's on the floor and then I
stick my dick in like that and this is
it's really smart and feels way better
if the girls spinning clockwise
underneath so it's like a helicopter
where you're both in motion the
helicopter is when you go to check doggy
and then you start to go like that you
don't stop drink you're making the rotor
of the hell yeah one's a slang the other
way is just to make that nice and the
submarine is when you're under check and
then you stick your hand up indoor [ __ ]
and then you start to look around yeah
they love that [ __ ] you should try it
yeah you're right tonight yeah okay what
I have here is shelter in place
damn all these weird words a noun an
official order issued during an
emergency that directs people to stay in
the indoor place or building that they
already occupy not not to leave unless
absolutely necessary
what if you were sheltering in place in
a hotel you got to pay all that money
yeah number like that couple that we
talked about namaz babies yeah dude look
at the homeless population man sixty
percent of the homeless population in
San Francisco has corona what yes so
they have to shelter yeah we have a
social shelter you know exactly I heard
about I heard about the
County it's a face mask getting abandon
Embassy Suites Hotels to shelter in home
at a four-star hotel like that is it
person Embassy Suites MSU school is up
but it's abandoned I don't think it's
that good but the minute you are inside
are not homeless anymore so you don't
qualify for the homeless Minister they
got to kick you out well no I mean it's
not home okay it's a shelter here any
words right now without a face mask to
face back why is your nose sticking out
of the back your ears are hurting I got
a face mask I can't believe a lot of
people out there take this show very
seriously the [ __ ] that I say with my
hair like this or like this and I'm just
like Coronas not real oh well they
usually see that and they go I need Joe
to teach me about business
we are the money masters we are the
money masters mm-hmm so we're gonna find
this we have a site and Ramallah Academy
and we have a $500,000 course that were
only just this learned it's our only
only for a limited time that's been
unlimited for right now for only $19.99
that's a 99.99% discount or doing right
now it's a Joe and Steve quarantine
program two weeks it's edited video
every day 14 days and it's really just
to help everybody yeah when does the
price go back to half a million dollars
soon very soon oh it's an get it soon
gotta hurry up yeah very soon it's a
limited time offer
yep and then we get a friend Cisco right
no we're gonna give you so much [ __ ]
value for so cheap
yeah your [ __ ] mine just Handy
something for free or do you want to
work for it
no and then you'll feel like you earned
it yep free your that you're the type of
person who wouldn't succeed anyway with
the significant about your course I want
you to take the course and go you know
what I spent money so I'm gonna do this
because I spent money I don't want you
to be like it's free so I could do it
whenever yeah whatever I want
I'll tell you like a free app on my
phone I don't use it that much yeah not
bad but the ones that you pay for you
use all the time it's actually the
opposite with me just like your alarms
nothing makes sense I know I'm weird as
soon as I pay for for something in an
app I no longer use it I don't know why
that's true all the games you play
they're free you play a non-stop
I spent like ten bucks on Pokemon go and
the next day I stopped using it you are
why guys go I can't figure out when it
like that the math sucks on this I
always try to have your back with that
thank you and I have your back too in a
different way
solve all my problems now I'm like
because you know how and only need to do
a math like teachers like show your work
Kasey's like it never leads to the same
thing I don't blame you man that's what
we're married cuz I literally feel
exactly like where's the equation TIFF
is like a forest that keeps growing so
even though you create a path to get to
her every [ __ ] spring a new it grows
and you got to find a new path oh and
then you asked her she asked you to make
the path and then halfway into you're
making it she's like why you making this
path here oh my god story my life yes
not even accurate because you know what
happens I give them a map I say here are
all the paths you need and you decide to
create a new one terracotta finish aka
current finish because I know these
things because of animal crossing thank
you I know because of Minecraft yeah
there's terracotta a new materials time
a season and new materials and getting
tests like no please usually old
outdated materials they're proven
tried-and-true anyway we're talking
about dictionary.com here what other
what other terms have you guys come
across that you're like oh [ __ ] that's
new
like for me quarantine people I didn't
use it them no lo yeah I haven't seen
did I make it to dictionary.com Yolo in
place they say that I never get her to
zoom until this meaning really FaceTime
each other like what happened to Skype
yes guys pizza Skype dude they're like
wheat for years we did brand awareness
hello everyone fact zum-zum zum-zum I
don't know I like zoom more than Skype
though just using it and in like
conferences and it's kind of like when
you dial into a [ __ ] chat and you
don't have to have you don't have to
give out your number and all that that's
true you just click a link mm-hmm it is
easier has anyone tried the house party
app what no I haven't tried it either
but I've seen it on the Internet what
does it do
it's like another facetiming thing I
don't know you haven't tried it cuz you
paid for it right exactly
hey I paid $50 subscription never put my
phone down
Jesus I'm surprised you guys are even
living in the home that you bought stay
at a shelter right now you buy it you
move origin and then she's like let's
move
[Music]
[Music]